yeah welcome to this video well blitz
game against a von Drago yeah this is
some from the what's this rocky for yeah
this is part four right the Russian
boxer played by Dolph Lundgren okay so
yeah let's play the three line there's
also the exchange variation which is not
bad at all but ok this is the slightly
more aggressive way to to play night to
e8 interesting ok yeah I'm ready to play
against F 595 you know probably walk g
water fighting against the f5 move hmm
yeah don't think he still can't play at
five the question is so what move do i
play now
and maybe queen of three I like Wiener
three still very tough to play a
five-term i'm preparing to two casts a
long yeah it's hard to see ya this is
basically the only play and it's it's
it's it's not good for black the only
question is am I able to refute it
download its simply simply bad it just
opens up your your position for no for
no real on compensation but let's see
how to how to play the snow should I
take on c5 and take on f5 so not bad
probably yeah keep it simple the Sun is
simple and good Bishop d3 is also not
bad but is a Queen's got f4 I don't want
or dad I should get control over the
foursquare Mia okay okay
yup should take it I'm not so much shown
and queen geforce was my idea not if
i'll need to get get this 96 of the bot
queen f6 i have 94 not so sure what
black ourselves playing now how is it
covering 27 rook f7 as i always play 95
they see them again here yeah probably
want to exchange the night so that at
the end I've got this strong knight on
e4 against the bishop on g7
we have been tending Queen g6 and take
on d6 maybe also Queen g6 check at the
root G form ya know maybe I've got
something benefit ok this is I think
good this cabbage some f4e for and
threatens to put the next stroke on the
G ha the good thing is I only need to
exchange all heavy pieces that are
winning the end game with the knight on
e4 against them against the bishop so
now just here right how to play this now
that is some to handling this try to go
kingi to covering f2 and I hope he
doesn't have any weird counterplay ideas
I looking for something maybe be 55 is
going for be five
yeah it's all very hard to believe but
ok never be five I hope to get rook g7
in its not winning unfortunately
now the position is is winning but 20
seconds time morning yeah I don't have
any time letting Luke age 6 Jack Jack
Jack Jack Jack Oh 22 moves two moves at
the end and he got one second yeah okay
i blundered a couple of you see because
it but needed to play it so quickly I am
yeah it's always a bit tricky this is
this kind of this kind of position i had
so often in bits games it's basically a
terrible for black but you always need
to be cautious because of your somewhat
open King position this is the kind of
position which you win absolutely and on
autopilot and
in a tournament game because black will
never make you but and in blitz it's
always always a bit tricky No No maybe I
had something substantially better but
it's not easy yeah okay you can just
take this our rook takes a four-year
wins and there should be something
because of Knight f6 mmm this was was
winning yeah here route takes a phone
they are dears after this kink oh yeah
yeah I can fly can give a couple of
checks yeah if you want and the problem
is that after this yeah it's either this
or after this position is also this with
winning he causes all soul mate yeah
yeah but tone okay I didn't in this
position I only thought okay let's play
Knight c3 and cover this and it's also
plus plus and what plus three or
something but the game continues and he
can steer troubled yeah thanks for
watching